Functions are special R objects
that take in other
objects as arguments and
produce something.
In many cases, the person who
wrote the function provides
default values for some or
even all the arguments.
We've now seen a couple of
important functions and
techniques.
First we saw the concatenate
function that was used to
create vectors.
And we saw we could create
vectors that are sequences of
integers using the integer
colon integer notation.
We used the length, head, and
tail functions to learn more
about vectors.
We also saw character vectors.
The letters object is a built-in
vector of letters
inside of R. If we wanted,
we could exam the
subset of the letters.
We also saw how to construct
matrices using the matrix
function, as well as how to
specify the number of rows and
columns for a matrix using the
second and third arguments.
The dim function provided
the way to check the
dimensions of a matrix.
And we could again use brackets
to examine a subset
of the matrix, except that we
specified both rows and
columns or just one.
Videos are great, but they're no
stand-in for documentation.
Thankfully, most functions in
R are very well documented.
To access the Help file for a
function, just type a question
mark, the function name,
and then hit Return.
Here's the Help file for
the sequence function.
At the top of the file is a
description of the sequence
function and other related
functions described
in this Help file.
The next section shows
the sequence
function and its variance.
And the argument section
provides details for what type
of inputs are reasonable
and how to
specify additional options.
The next sections of particular
interest are the
See Also and Example sections.
It's a good idea to take a look
at the Example section
early on when you're exploring
a new function.
On OS X, it's also easy to run
examples from the Help file
but highlighting the example
text, holding down Command,
and then hitting Return.
Congratulations!
You've completed the first
section of R videos.
Take some time to try out
what you've learned.
And when R gives you an error,
check for typing mistakes,
which are common.
After you've finished
experimenting, fuel up and
start Section 2.